if
See you church. Happy April. Does that mean it's officially spring
now? I think maybe we'll see in the next couple weeks.
But if you hear last week, you know that we kicked off
a really brief sermon series on this
idea of helping us see how
the gospels which again are the first four books the New
Testament help us believe in Jesus.
How does how does those four books
help us believe? We saw that each one of them
were written not just as biographies about
Jesus, but they were written as gospel accounts of
Jesus's life death and
Resurrection in the place of Sinners Like You and Me.
Not just biograph.
IES, they are gospel accounts. And so last week
we looked at Matthews account of the gospel and
this week. We're going to look at marks viewpoint on the
gospel. And so take your copy of God's word if you're not already there
and turn with me to The Gospel According to
mark
Will be a chapter 16 to start with so you
can go all the way to the end of Mark.
And we're going to get there in a moment.
but as you're turning it, let me remind you of something that I talked
to you, especially kids and students last week, but really all of
us that this Study last week this week and next
week May challenge you
at times it's gonna feel like an upper level course and
you're gonna have to have to think a little bit more than maybe before
but but really how we're supposed to understand God's
word is the point the focus of this. I know
you can handle it. I know we can step up to that
as we go forward.
But whether this is new information for you or not.
the point
of all of this
Even listen even if you've doubted this stuff.
You haven't believed you're just like are this all is just a
lot of hogwash. No, this is this is the point of
this is to reawaken our hearts.
To see that that The Wonder of
the gospel and the Wonder and depth of God's grace for
us is true and it's worthy of Our
Lives.
to help us believe
And so to get there last week, we had to start a journey
into the nature of these first four books than Testament.
Like how did we even get them? Like these good news
accounts. We call the gospels. What are they? What is it
mean to be a gospel?
We saw that their eyewitness testimonies to Jesus's life.
Now now as we looked at them, we saw the diverse, right? These are individuals
writing with angles and focuses.
But they all have a thread that cohesively runs
through all of them.
So the gospel truth those core elements about who Jesus is and
what he's done and and we saw that the Holy Spirit inspired each
of those uniquely so that we are not
so that we're confused so that we have a deeper and richer portrait
of Jesus.
And we learn more and see who he is and we're challenged and
encouraged by the Gospels.
We're going to study Mark in that way today.
Now I said it last week at times. We're gonna
get kind of technical in these sermons.
This is one of those times about to Wade in to a
little bit of technicalities on some things but even as I
say that
I know that some of you showed up today and just like man, I just need some
encouragement.
I'm hurting my life is falling
apart and you're up there about to lecture us on textual criticism.
And I know that sounds like how is this even matter? Why does
this help me?
Why do we need to know these things? Why is this important?
Well, here's the reality.
For whatever reason in those circumstances of life
that push us to those places for whatever
reason we've taken our eyes off of
Jesus in those moments.
And we start looking around at our circumstances and we start
looking around it at these things being ultimate.
And it leads us to despair or or doubt or
trouble or whatever else and we we look at
those things way more than we look at Jesus
or maybe literally again, like you said, like I
said before you walked in here, you don't even believe this stuff.
Okay. Well listen.
all of this
is to help you believe.
Everything about to talk about is to help you believe that
this is true and trustworthy. I
hope to give you some confidence today.
And if you don't believe this you can that if you do believe this
that you can stand firm.
That what you read here is true and trustworthy it tells
you who God really is and you can believe this.
So what that is our foundation here's here's where we're
gonna get a little technical in mark.
You're at Mark 16. I want you to look.
closely Mark chapter 16
if you noticed right after verse 8
Pretty quickly into chapter 16 right after verse 8 now. This
is unless you have the King James version. This is not there. But but
it has in an insertion in there that says
something like some of the earliest manuscripts do
not include 16 9 through 20.
You see that?
And then there's there's double brackets around versus nine
through 20. Now. The question is
why is that?
Some of you have never even seen it that's
there before.
Well to understand what this is intending. We
need to understand first how we even received what
we have in God's word.
Next we're gonna get back into to how did we even get this?
Especially the New Testament. How did we
get this?
Well, as people were recording things like this
and Mark marks writing these things down. They were translating the
generally spoken Aramaic around them into
Greek as they wrote it down.
Now again, any translation is interpretation
in itself. And so we can trust as they
were doing that the Holy Spirit was superintending
even that as well. So
we know that that God was having him right down what he
wanted to communicate right? So it's not just
that because we don't have Aramaic it's not right. It's also right
that way.
unfortunately
We don't have any of those original manuscripts.
That's what those documents that they're writing down. We call a manuscripts manuscripts
and so we don't have any of
those.
anymore
thankfully though.
Once that original or those Originals of any
of these books began to be circulated.
Describes would make copies for safe keeping and
for wider distribution.
Here's the problem though 2,000 years ago. They couldn't just go to FedEx Office and
start making copies of it.
A copyist had to hand write with
quill and ink on parchment. They had to
hand write it all out.
So think about that as you're writing something in school
or writing a letter which a few people still do now, right? Like
you're riding it you're gonna make mistakes. You're gonna be slips. There's
gonna be things that you don't copy exactly over right that would
happen.
That's why when we talk about the inerrancy of
God's word.
We're talking strictly speaking about
the original manuscripts.
Those things that were originally written were without
error as God intended wanted them to be
written down.
Now I know as soon as I say that.
The minds are going where you're thinking like. Okay, well.
Well, does that mean what we have now is not God's word because
if that's if that was inerrancy, this is not an errancy. So
so listen, I'm not trying to create doubt.
About God's word.
Because what you might be thinking is alright, so there's Originals then
there's copies and you're thinking of that telephone game that
you played when you were in elementary school where somebody Whispers a
phrase to one person like, hey, the elephant
is sleeping and then they whisper it and they whisper it
and they whisper it all the way around the circle and somehow it comes out on the other end like
the semi truck ran off the road. Like, I don't know how that happens.
But it does right and so, you know, you're thinking okay if they're making
copies and there were errors along the way then what we
have is all out of control. No.
Here's how we can trust.
That what we have here.
Faithfully represents the originals
see over the centuries archaeologists have discovered thousands
of copies of these
documents.
Many of them look just like this you'll see the picture on
the screen.
And their parchment they're not made of paper. Like we
have there's different types of papers throughout the history of
the world and parchment was one of them. So what
they do with those is they date those documents closer
and closer back to the original documents
and then they have so many
they cross-check them for accuracy and they see
well this one over here we found in Libya says this this one in Syria
says this and they cross-check them and
what they found is that of the ancient authentic copies.
They've discovered they match over 99%
Over 99% of the authentic ancient manuscripts.
They're finding they match.
In fact many more manuscripts exist
for the New Testament than for any other
ancient writings out there.
Just for example.
There are over 5,600 early
New Testament Greek manuscripts.
While there are only seven of Plato's
writings.
5600 of Greek New
Testament seven
of Plato's writings
Along with that. There's over 19,000 copies in
Syriac Latin Coptic and Aramaic languages.
Not just the Greek. Those were again copies in different languages.
That's over 24,000 supporting
manuscripts.
We even have a copy of the fragment of
the copy of the Gospel according to
John.
That dates back to about 29 years
from when John would have originally written it
down in the late first century 29
years that's unheard of
in any other ancient text.
What that does though? Is it verifies the
authenticity of that copy? Because 29 years
means somebody would have been alive to have read
the original.
And if they see the copy is messed up in some
way. They might hold up. No. No, that's not what John wrote.
And they would have been able to point out and complain about the the inaccuracy of
the copy. And so you see how that saying what that
copy says if it's 29 years man, that's
that's verifying.
compare that to Homer's Iliad
Where the closest copy from the original is 500 years
later.
But we sure don't question. Its reliability as much
do we
so again
what I'm saying with all of this.
Is that we can trust that what we have
is God's word.
We can believe that God providentially ensured
the transmission of his
word just as much as he did the initial writing
of it.
That's really important for us so we can believe right.
If you notice though, I did not say 100% agreement
among the manuscripts.
99.5% is what
we have and so are there some differences
when they find this one over here and this one over here and this one from
this year and and they they look at those are there some differences?
Yes.
But hear me those differences are very minor.
They're often dealing with like a missing letter or
missing word and or a plural versus singular and
this copy and and you start to
see well, maybe This coffee's just kind of missed that word things that
don't affect theological principles in
any way.
Right when you look at your Bible, you'll see at the bottom. There's probably
footnotes down there.
And that's where you'll see stuff like that.
Well certain manuscripts say this word or that word,
but you read it. You're like that doesn't affect anything in our faith actually.
It's just there.
There are only two big sections in the
New Testament where there's substantial disagreement.
The double brackets here in Mark 16 is one of those.
The other one is in John chapter 8 with the woman caught in adultery. That's
another section that's similar to this.
And so what we're going to get to do today?
I set the foundation that we're going to do is we're gonna see how that reception of
God's word develops here and Mark.
Like that that reality of what we've seen with manuscripts
and how to do it all like then we're gonna get see it happen here
in Mark see an example of it of what we do
because remember what did it say here some of
the earliest manuscripts do not include 16 9 through
20. Now, you know what that's saying, right?
Some of the ones they found from the earliest dating they
could find they don't have 16 9
through 20.
Okay, but that leads the question. Why would some
copies later apparently include this
section?
well, because if you end the
book with verse 8
It ends pretty a pretty suddenly.
So here's where we're at in the the story the women
have come to the tomb the they noticed that
the The Rock's been rolled away that Jesus body is
not there an angel shows up and says, hey Jesus is actually alive go
to Galilee and he'll meet you there.
We'll look at verse 8, Matthew or Mark 6:16.
And they went out the women they went out and fled
from the tomb for trembling and astonishment had
seized them and they said nothing to anyone for they
were afraid.
You see how abrupt that would be like, that's it.
That's why somebody's looking to this like surely. There's got to be something else, right?
But again, the earliest manuscripts do oddly end
it like that.
It is kind of an odd ending right in verse
8 ends with and they didn't tell anybody like so
so certainly we would think okay. That's why
either when the when copyist got that document. That's
why they thought okay. Well either we lost
Mark's original ending because certainly he
couldn't end it like that right either. We lost it somewhere along
the way.
Like hey, they forgot to staple the last page
of the document to go. Hey, here's the full thing. No that
either we lost it or more probably
this.
This is how Mark wanted to end it.
because listen
Listen to how Mark.
began
Mark 1 verse 1 the beginning
of the Gospel of Jesus Christ the son of
God
see what it says.
the beginning
that means chapter 16 is not the end of
the story.
That this is a beginning all
of Mark that he's written in one through 16 is
foundational for the rest of time for our
faith the gospel, but God's work
continues today, doesn't it?
And this was intended possibly by Mark to pull
us into the story.
To say okay. Well then what what do you
do with this information?
Apparently those some copious later.
They tried to smooth out the rough
edges of Mark 16 in the ending of it.
They felt was appropriate this this ending
here. Unfortunately, the longer ending
versus 9 through 20 is debatable.
Because in part it doesn't match the rest of
Mark.
It changes the tone as it speaks. It
repeats things. It probably wouldn't repeat if it
was original from Mark.
It has words used nowhere else in mark.
So we look at these verses and and we think like, okay.
Well that sure doesn't seem to match even further it claims
that Jesus said this this is Mark 16:17
and 18.
Jesus says these signs will accompany those
who believe.
In my name they will cast out demons. They will speak
in new tongues. They will pick up serpents with their
hands and if they drink any deadly poison, it will not
hurt them.
They will lay their hands on the sick and they
will recover.
By the way, if you have the King James version of the Bible
in your hands.
Which was translated into English in the year 1611.
It doesn't have the brackets.
Here's why?
Well, this is also why you'll see King James only churches practice
snake handling and drinking poison in their services.
It's because they hold this as authentic. This
is what Jesus said is going to happen for those who believe
again though. The problem is that the King
James version is based from 1611 on
later manuscripts.
Since they translated into English is 1611. We
found manuscripts that are earlier than what they used.
And they don't have this section.
Okay. So again.
What do we do with this?
I'm not trying to end out induce got a doubt
in God's word here. That's not the goal of this today. We need
to be able to answer this question though.
So you're not reading through and you're doubting God's word as a
whole because of this section. What do we do with it?
Here's what One Pastor said about this section in Mark
16.
In spite of all these considerations of the likely unreliability
of this section.
Since it is possible to be wrong on the issue. It's good
to consider the meaning of this passage and leave it in the
text. Just like we do with John chapter 8.
Yet while for the most part summarizing truths
taught elsewhere in Scripture.
Meaning you can find the majority of 9 through 20 elsewhere and
scripture.
Verses 9 through 20 should always be compared with the
rest of scripture and no doctrines should
be formulated based solely on these verses.
That's what we do with this section.
Handle it carefully.
So there's part obviously here of chapter 16 that differs slightly
from the rest of the Gospels.
Mark in some small ways differs
from the other three
But I did it last week and I want to do it again this week
where where we highlight a couple of other ways that
Mark is different.
A couple other unique elements that Mark includes that
the other three gospels don't and why would Mark do
that?
We'll do it again next week with John.
But here's the first one just to the left in Mark chapter
15 verse 21 go over
there with me. Just turn one page to the left scroll up a little bit mark 15:21.
We're gonna look at this briefly. And again the scene
here. Is that Jesus remember as he was
arrested and tried he was then physically
unable to carry his own cross
because he had been beaten and tortured within
an inch of his life.
I mean it was it was almost deadly what they
did before they even got to the cross. And so that's where we are
right now. That's why this happens in verse 21
of Mark 15.
They compelled a pastor by Simon of
Cyrene who was coming in from the country the father
of Alexander and Rufus to carry Jesus's
cross.
Now here's the thing. The other gospels mentioned that
Simon carries Jesus cross. That's that's not
unique to Mark. What's unique is the mention of
Simon's Sons Alexander and Rufus.
Nobody else mentions them and Mark writes
it as if his readers would know
Alexander and Rufus.
Like oh, yeah those guys remember Alexander, you know them right? He's mentioning
them as if they would know them. By the way,
it's likely the same Rufus that Paul mentions
in Romans chapter 16 verse 13 where
he says greet Rufus to the Roman Church
greet Rufus chosen in the Lord also his mother
who's been a mother to me as well.
So Paul knows Rufus Mark's readers
know Rufus. So here's what happened in
Mark 15. This is digging in a little bit deeper to this
one verse.
Here's what happened.
When Simon was forced to carry jesus' cross.
God put Simon face to face with the
one who could carry his sins.
We don't know if Simon new Jesus before this moment or not, but he is
having to carry the cross and he's looking right at Jesus.
But what happened as a result?
It's clear that Simon believed right?
Not only he believed but he goes home and he tells
his wife and he tells his sons about this Jesus that
he got to carry the cross for and he says I couldn't do
anything but no that that's the savior of the world and so his whole
family then comes to faith in Christ and
that family then we see in Romans 16 gives
their lives for the church for
the rest of their lives.
That that's Simon's wife rufus's mom.
His is a mom to Paul.
Serving caring loving him like he
is her own son.
And Mark here included their names so
that people could confirm these things
that Mark's writing down.
Right because think about Alexander Rufus as they were around the disciples
early in the church as they were around Paul clearly.
Like they would have been asking questions. They would have known that what Mark
was writing is absolutely true.
It's worthy of being trusted. It's worthy of being believed.
I mean to us we just skate over that stuff, right?
We don't even read it. It's such a minor detail, but Mark wanted his
readers to believe right?
He wanted his readers to be certain of this account of
Jesus. And so he's like guys if you doubt this stuff go ask Alexander
and Rufus they know.
Like they were maybe there we don't know.
But they know this is true.
God was continuing to oversee the spread of his
gospel.
That it was true. It was right. It's trustworthy.
One more place. I want to take you in Mark. It's just another page
to the left. Keep going a little bit further scroll up
to the left chapter 14.
Will be in verses 51 and 52 of Mark 14
again. These are unique moments in Mark that
no one else in the gospels includes.
Now we keep going back in time. So the scene here is
the night before Jesus was crucified.
This is in the Garden of Gethsemane.
Jesus had just eaten his Passover meal with his disciples washed their
feet. Then he takes them out to the Garden here.
to pray together
Jesus knows what's about to come?
And so he needs to pray.
That Garden is also where Judas betrayed Jesus.
Where Judas gave Jesus over to the crowd
and the guard to be arrested and tried and eventually crucified like
we saw with Simon scene.
I'm going to start reading up in verse 48 though.
This is Jesus responding to judas's betrayal.
To the crowd clamoring for Jesus.
Look at verse 48. Jesus said to them. Have you come out
as against a robber?
With swords and clubs to capture
me.
Day after day I was with you in the temple teaching and
yet you did not seize me.
But let the scriptures be fulfilled.
This is all prophetic. This is not an accident.
So that's how Jesus responded but but look
at how the disciples responded to the crowd though.
verse 50
and they all left him.
fled
it's his disciples. They
now that's in the other gospels that that the crowd shows
up. Jesus gets betrayed.
Peter might have used a sword to cut a guy's
ear off, but but eventually they all ran.
They all fled they left him they abandoned him.
That's in the other gospels, but look.
At what we see in verses 51 and 52. This
part is unique to mark
and a young man followed him.
With nothing, but a linen cloth about his body.
And they the guards seized him.
But he left the linen cloth and ran away
naked.
What?
Like this thing's so serious and you're all feeling it for so long, right? Oh, just
seriously talk about the Gospels.
and then this
What in the world is going on here? Why is that even in
here? First of all?
It's almost like the disciples are sitting around years later. There's
like hey, remember the naked guy and I just laughing at
each other.
What is this?
Why in the world would Mark include those two
verses nobody else did none of the other three gospels did but Mark
does.
Plus, how did it even know what happened?
Right, the guards wouldn't have told him.
Right, and there's there's no one else there because everybody
else had fled.
So, how does Mark know?
That's why I think this is.
My opinion I think Mark included this
because that was him.
I think that was Mark now. I can't know that for sure.
I'm not gonna die on that hill of course, but it's just interesting to think about. How did
this transmission happen? How did we get the stories? We
got in the Gospels?
Mark knew and he didn't really want to share that with him.
but it was
True but more importantly here more importantly than who it
was.
What Mark was doing here?
Was he was highlighting how everyone had
abandoned Jesus?
Like in his deepest moment of need.
Of course all the other gospels talk about all the disciples
fled, but then Mark is saying man this one
young man.
Right he tried.
He was he was Valiant. He gave another he like Jesus been arrested. Everybody else is
leaving. He's he's like, oh man, I'm gonna make I'm gonna stand with Jesus, but
then even he fled
remember all these disciples had just a few hours earlier
stood up and said to Jesus like I'll die with
you Jesus.
I'll go to the Cross I'll do whatever I'll do whatever it takes
to follow you. I am in on this. I am not leaving
you.
They all left.
Even this bold young man.
Stuck it out the furthest.
Even he left abandoning. Jesus to be alone.
with the guards
in his deepest moment of need
Listen, that's the question. I want to ask you today.
Remember why the Holy Spirit inspired marked to
write all this?
So that people would believe.
So that people would believe that Jesus is the Messiah savior
Christ. The son of God that he is who
he said he is.
That's why the holy spirit said Mark right this yet even as
he was writing it down.
Mark and the other disciples would have known how easy
it is to abandon that
same Jesus when times get hard.
Listen a lot of people today.
Have been duped into believing that when you follow Jesus,
everything's gonna work out really well for your life.
Like you're gonna have a perfect family.
All kinds of money you're gonna be healthy.
Almost like God is some kind of bank vault in
the sky that if you get the combination, right you're opening the
door and you get everything on the other side of it.
That's just not true.
and and sadly what happens if someone believes
that
as soon as things get dicey.
As soon as things don't go their way.
They bail.
And then blame him for it.
I think that's why Mark included these two unique elements
that he included.
Because he wanted to deeply challenge those
who have been reading his document back
then.
Like why did he include the the Simon's son
thing? Why did he include this this man running away
naked? Why did he include usage? Because he wanted to deeply
challenge those who have been reading it back then
because I'm sure people could have gone up to Rufus and
and they could have they could have seen these
guys.
In Rome, and they would have thought they would have
seen that that their life wasn't great.
Like imagine following Jesus in Rome back then right? Like they they
would have seen that Alexander and Rufus man. They didn't have it good
for the rest of their lives. They had to struggle. They were persecuted. There
was some difficult Seasons, they walked through even though
they believed
Along with that Mark includes this factoid in
the garden this one little tiny thing as
a way.
to remind himself
and to remind every other disciple the
price of turning away from Jesus.
Right. Why would he put that in there?
Why would the Holy Spirit lead him to put that in there?
Now I know at the time they did not
understand the power of the Resurrection yet. They did not have the Holy Spirit
of God dwelling in them as Believers yet. So that changed everything
a few weeks later. When the Holy Spirit entered in
they became bold. They became unashamed. Yes, everything changed,
but they included this I think
Because they needed to feel the sting
of the time. They had previously abandoned
and denied Jesus in his greatest
time of need.
Like just think of the way they would have felt
every time they read this.
Because you remember.
You remember how we ran?
So Mark wanted to challenge his readers.
But hear me church, I believe that from 2,000 years ago
marks writing to us too as well. And
he wants to challenge us just as deeply
he asks us the same question.
Do you believe that Jesus lived died
and resurrected in your place for your
salvation?
Do you believe that Jesus is your savior?
Listen if you don't yet.
then
I pray that you would see who he is.
And you would see that you can trust this talking about
him and you can turn to him in faith that he's done it
all for your salvation. I I pray that you would see that today.
But listen, if you do believe that
Jesus is the Risen Savior.
Like those women came to the tomb and they saw he's not there anymore.
The angel said he's alive. Do you believe that if you believe
that Jesus is your savior and
he is alive.
And why are you ashamed to stand for him?
Why do you run like the disciples did?
When things get a little dicey.
And then you somehow blame God for your pain.
Why do you abandon Jesus when the
angry mob comes your way?
Why why do we deny him
in the way? We live our lives that it's
no different than anybody out there who doesn't believe and it
looks no different.
Like maybe you need to see today that you're clinging
tighter to the things of this world. You're clinging
to security. There's a comfort or to pleasure.
Like maybe you're clinging more tightly to keeping
up your reputation than you are then worried about
the honor of Christ in your life.
I mean, just think about this have you truly counted the
cost to follow Jesus?
Mark calls us to believe
he calls us to see this
unchanging God and he says trust him.
He says follow him. He's worthy of it.
That's how you persevere Church.
Listen, you're seeing this and you might be feeling this
weight creeping on your shoulders that you have to somehow come
up with the power yourself to say. Well, I've got
to stand strong for Jesus now, I guess. Okay, how can I drum that
up? Here we go.
now listen
as you just saw from the disciples.
You cannot do this on your own.
You cannot do this on your you're gonna run.
I will run.
We are not strong enough.
So, how do you persevere? How do you stand how do
you stay steadfast? How do you do this? Listen, the
way you do? This is by abiding in
Jesus. It's by immersing
yourself into this gospel. This
good news constantly because as
you do that he empowers you
to persevere.
You look at this and you're like, there's no way that angry
mobs coming at me. I'm out really fast. Yes, that
is true. But you cannot forget this church.
You cannot forget the truth that Jesus lived the
life. You can't live in your place. He died the death
you deserved in your place. He resurrected to defeat sin
and death in your place. He did all of that for you.
So now it's not your job to come up with it yourself. It's your
job to rest in him. So he does it through you.
And so you stand there the angry mobs coming
your way. What do you do? You say Jesus? I desperately need
you and it gives you the power to stand.
That's what we're talking about here. That is what he
did to save us to redeem us
to sustain us. He did it all that's the
gospel truth that we hold dear.
But again, if that's true.
then
what else can we do but give it all back to
him?
To count Our Lives as nothing for the
sake of following him.
To say to Jesus. Here's my money. Here's my time.
Here's my friends. Here's my habits.
Here's my path. Here's my shame. Here's my
safety. Here's my sin. Here's my life.
Say to Jesus it's yours and
to say in a way even if standing with
you. Jesus means I die.
even if standing with you, Jesus means I get made fun of
it means I get taken advantage of it means
I lose.
Even if it means I don't have as much as I could otherwise,
whatever it is Jesus you are
worth it.
And I believe Jesus I believe.